[Musica]
[Applauso]
che magnifica opportunità io devo dire
che quando sono stata invitata subito
appena mi hanno telefonato ero già grata
grata per il fattore mi invitassero
Quando poi mi è stato comunicato il tema
mutazioni lo ero ancora di più adesso
provo subito e riuscì perché ho detto è
perfetto mutazioni Io voglio raccontare
come è cambiato come mutato il rapporto
tra la mia generazione
e il lavoro e il lavoro che faccio
Quindi racconterò di me adesso insieme a
voi invece
ripercorrerò ciò che ha fatto mutare
l'oggetto stesso di questo Talk che è
mutato in corsa Io sono nata nel
1978 esattamente quando sul numero 49 di
Annabella una rivista dedicata alle
donne
usciva questo supplemento il libro
pratico della donna
l'ho messo come riferimento perché è
divertente Come vedete ci sono tante
mani che tengono in
mano tiene un oggetto diverso ed è un
chiaro riferimento a tutte le cose che
le donne come giocolieri devono riuscire
a tenere in equilibrio
Ma quando ero piccola erano i ruggenti
anni 80 nella nel tolc della
professoressa Schillaci c'è stato
trasferito l'entusiasmo che c'era negli
anni 80 per il mondo del lavoro
io ascoltavo moltissimo gli adulti e
molto presto direi quasi in età
prescolare avevo già deciso cosa volevo
fare io volevo
raccontare storie
leggere storie e questo grazie a tre
donne della mia vita
in ordine di grandezza di età una prozia
che sapeva raccontare benissimo delle
storie che appartengono al nostro
patrimonio orale una nonna che non
conosceva nessuna storia e se le
inventava è una madre che aveva la
pazienza di leggermeli ogni sera quindi
avrò avuto sei anni quando
avevo individuato perfettamente qual era
il lavoro ideale da fare per poter
raccontare e leggere storie
il pensionato
signori negli anni 80 la pensione era un
mito
e io vedevo Questi signori maschi non a
caso ho detto il pensionato che nel
pieno dell'età sessantenni si godevano
la vita raccontavano storie leggevano il
giornale a Mario gli ho detto questo il
lavoro che voglio fare io
Grazie
[Applauso]
le cose sono mutate per me la pensione
resterà per sempre un mito Per fortuna
me l'hanno raccontata quando ero piccole
esattamente come le storie della
buonanotte però sono riuscita a fare lo
stesso quello che desideravo fare a 6
anni io in modo rocambolesco racconto e
leggo storie lo faccio scrivendo sulle
pagine di Repubblica nell'edizione
siciliana leggendo i libri e
recensendoli prevalentemente
lo faccio da autrice
e lo faccio occupandomi di idraulica
della narrazione c'è un romanzo che
perde io lo aggiusto c'è qualcuno che ha
bisogno di mettere a fuoco una
comunicazione a livello anche di
compagnia di azienda io intervengo vengo
chiamata con la mia borsetta degli
attrezzi intervengo e aggiusto la
narrazione
lungo termine Non so se adesso sono già
passibile di multa inglese si dice Ghost
Rider
ancora non mi mutano quindi Perdonatemi
facciamo insieme Questo ragionamento ho
detto adesso racconto
appunto come mutato il mio rapporto col
mondo del lavoro
Ho anche un passato al quale tengo molto
da linguista per cui per me le parole
sono molto importanti ho detto va bene
Allora partiamo da Che cos'è una
mutazione una mutazione è proprio l'atto
del mutare ed è interessante notare che
nel 90% dei casi mutazione è usato come
sinonimo perfetto di cambiamento
però attenzione Io so che la lingua come
tutto segue il principio dell'economia
quindi non possono esistere due termini
che dicano esattamente la stessa cosa
tutte le volte che noi ci troviamo a
maneggiare dei sinonimi dobbiamo cercare
di capire qual è la differenza Allora
Perdonate la pedanteria ma il suffisso
mento indica il concetto in astratto il
cambiamento è
l'azione del cambiare in astratto la
mutazione ha a che fare col processo in
atto o con il risultato dell'azione e
Perdonatemi se vi faccio notare che
produce soltanto nomi femminili
quindi mutazione il processo il
risultato del mutare e allora ho detto
Bene allora andiamo a vedere quali sono
i più grandi le più grandi mutazioni che
riguardano L'ultimo periodo l'ultimo
secolo gli ultimi 50 anni e secondo me
sono gli stessi cioè cliccando su Google
sono gli stessi che tutti noi tutti voi
state pensando in questo momento c'è la
mutazione climatica che secondo me è
molto più giusto chiamare mutazione
climatica e cambiamento La
globalizzazione la rete Come è cambiata
la mobilità come è cambiata la finanza
è per un attimo mentre facevo ero
orientata verso questo tipo di tolco ho
detto Aspetta ma manca qualcosa
è il talk di stasera che ha avuto prima
di me delle speaker eccezionali ne è la
prova
allora ho fatto una cosa da racconta
storie effettivamente un po’altro sono
andata a riguardare la parola mutazione
e ho cercato di vedere se per caso
nascosta ci fosse un altro Significato
ed è venuto fuori mute azioni e ho detto
Ma non è che per caso visto che secondo
me manca qualcosa tra le più grandi
mutazioni dell'ultimo secolo c'è
qualcosa di silenzioso che sta avvenendo
ma non è ancora sufficientemente urlato
Anche se questo Ted Io parlo per ultima
lo smentisce già
E allora sono andato a vedere quand'è
che è stata fondata la prima università
la prima università nella storia
dell'umanità è un'università che viene
fondata nel
1088 in Italia Bologna e giustamente
viene chiamata Alma
Mater
Alma Mater è la madre nutrice ed è un
appellativo che di solito viene data
alla dea Cerere afimina Mura che c'è in
piazza Umberto I
Peccato che nel 1088 questa madre
nutrice
Alma Mater studiorum quindi la madre
nutrice degli studi e degli studiosi
avesse a cuore di nutrire soltanto figli
maschi perché sapete Quand'è che le
donne hanno accesso all'università e il
1874 è stato un pochino di tempo è
passato un pochino di tempo questo non
vuol dire che alcune donne
non siano riuscite a laurearsi prima ci
sono state
singole eccezioni E come ha detto in
maniera commovente ed eccellente la
professoressa Schillaci prima
che sia una eroica che nonostante tutto
conquisti un obiettivo non è importante
tra le mute azioni in corso
soprattutto in Occidente ormai Ovunque
ma soprattutto in Occidente Mi spiace
dover essere ancora costretta a fare
questa specifica non possiamo non
menzionare lo spazio che le donne si
stanno apprendendo lo spazio pubblico
che le donne si stanno prendendo perché
lo spazio privato ce l'abbiamo sempre
avuto ma è tutta un'altra storia e
quelle ancora che si devono prendere
perché dal 1088 al 1874 è un gap
che ci vuole del tempo Per colmare e non
a caso un poco di dati
abbiamo 80 rettori e solo 9 rettrici
quotidiani mensili settimanali sono
diretti in percentuali molto ridotte
dalle donne piuttosto che dagli uomini
nonostante le lettrici siano di più dei
lettori i ruoli apicali all'interno
dell'editoria sono ricoperti ancora da
uomini
Premio Strega settante edizioni soltanto
non ricordo quante 10 Sono state vinte
da da scrittrici va detto è una
mutazione da registrare che
nell'edizione di quest'anno su 12
finalisti ben otto sono scrittrici
quindi sicuramente sta cambiando
qualcosa 112 premi Nobel assegnati alla
letteratura soltanto 17 sono stati
assegnati a delle scrittrici è il 90 per
cento di questi negli ultimi 30 anni
siamo l'unica minoranza trattata con
l'oppressione delle minoranze che non è
una minoranza perché noi non siamo una
minoranza numerica siamo la metà Siamo
state anche di più degli uomini adesso
il rapporto è veramente oscilla siamo su
cifre veramente irrisorie e differenza
la metafora che mi viene in mente è vi
chiedo di fare l'esperimento perché è
come se a un certo punto l'umanità pur
sapendo benissimo di avere a
disposizione due occhi abbia
deliberatamente deciso di usarne uno
solo e di guardarne di guardare il mondo
così
provateci provateci per un tempo
continuato
continuiamo a vedere Non è che se ci
tappiamo un occhio non vediamo più noi
vediamo
ma dopo pochissimo perdiamo la
profondità perché siamo fatti per vedere
con due occhi e questo dà una profondità
e credo che sia una metafora abbastanza
calzante
è un'altra cosa Non è che aprire
l'occhio all'improvviso un occhio che è
stato chiuso per secoli aprirlo
all'improvviso vuol dire anche avere
pazienza volontà e slancio per allenarlo
perché immediatamente quest'occhio sarà
ferito da una luce a cui non è abituato
e soprattutto guarda un mondo
che è pieno di
luoghi comuni e stereotipi e pensiero
che non sono fatti
per abbracciare la sua visione delle
cose qua ci sono due due citazioni
famosi una
nell'eneide di Virgilio Quindi quando si
dice che la donna è una banderuola che
cambia idea completamente come
costantemente e viene proprio citata
mentre viene raccontata la storia di
Didone in ed Enea Ora io non so tra
Didone Enea che abbandonò Enea che
abbandona di donne di notte fuggendo
dopo averla sedotta chi dei due
effettivamente una banderuola che cambia
idea costantemente
oppure ah
Sì la fragilità il tuo nome è Donna
Shakespeare anche lì Amleto aveva
qualche problema anche lui Io in questo
mondo però volevo dire costruito pensato
immaginato storicamente da uomini in
tutti i campi Nelle scienze nella musica
nelle città guardiamo le città le città
sono progettate da uomini e io certe
volte un po' mi scoraggio il pensiero
che non c'è più spazio per immaginare
città
progettate da delle donne progettate
interamente da zero dalle donne mi
conforta l'idea che andremo a progettare
città su altri pianeti io in questo
mondo in questo immaginario costruito da
giganti che sono stati al mio fianco
lungamente nella vita perché io io sono
cresciuta che A capotavola ci si sedeva
l'uomo che la porzione più grande la
doveva prendere l'uomo e mi è sempre
andato bene e ho amato Scusate torno
indietro ho amato i personaggi ho amato
il Don Chisciotte a modostoyevsky amo
l'idiota sono sono stati i miei fratelli
lungamente
Eppure
è arrivato un momento in cui ho pensato
vivo in un mondo veramente dove lo
spazio per il racconto femminile è
cominciato un attimo fa
è leggendo leggendo la letteratura come
tutti voi è abituata ad avere a che fare
con personaggi immaginati e pensati da
uomini anche personaggi femminili che
sono stati il modello di generazione di
donne ma partoriti dalla mente di un
uomo mi sono ritrovata nelle stesse
condizioni di questo personaggio che
dice Mentre leggevo mi scoprivo simile
Eppure allo stesso tempo diverso dagli
esseri di cui leggevo sapete chi è il
personaggio
Frankenstein
Frankenstein il mostro messo insieme da
tanti pezzi di esseri umani diversi
scritto da una donna Mary Shelley E
questo sentimento di estraneità al mondo
era il sentimento di estremità di una
donna che voleva creare voleva scrivere
e non c'era un mondo ancora pronto ad
accoglierla questo questa mutazione
nella mutazione come questa mutazione
nel tolc che volevo fare è la mutazione
che ho sperimentato
come donna grazie alle scrittrici
prevalentemente grazie alle narrazioni
femminili ha veramente mutato il mio
lavoro che si sta orientando in maniera
ben precisa come giornalista Io voglio
veramente partecipare all'epica
femminile voglio costruirla come
narratrice divulgarla come giornalista
vi racconto velocemente i progetti negli
ultimi progetti nei quali sono
coinvolta quest'estate il giornale qui
collaboro prevalentemente quindi
l'edizione siciliana in Repubblica mi ha
dato l'enorme opportunità di tenere una
rubrica che si chiamava L'isola delle
ragazze per tutta l'estate sono andata
in giro per la Sicilia a raccogliere le
storie di donne che stanno attuando
delle mutazioni importanti in vari campi
del Lavoro venne riassume brevemente 3
perché sono le tre questioni che mi
stanno più a cuore lei e Carmela
Petrillo è Favino a ragù a Siracusa
della sua storia vi racconto questa e
lei è un agricoltrice in tutto e per
tutto anche se è un percorso articolato
un possibile a quello di Paola viene da
studi diversi ma fa l'agricoltrice ogni
mattina si sveglia e vorrebbe avere
scritta sulla carta d'identità Carmela
Petrillo agricoltrice non è possibile
lei risulta agricoltore
molti sorridono sulla questione
linguistica è una cosa seria
se Voi chiedete un bambino che non ha
nessuna sovrastruttura non ha difficoltà
a dire che Carmela Petrillo è
un'agricoltrice noi attraverso la lingua
la lingua e lo strumento più importante
che abbiamo per crearcela la realtà è la
vita che viviamo manipolata da notizie
da comunicazione da quello che la lingua
ci racconta nella prova lei la prossima
e Claudia faozia a Palermo Leone
economista che studia il sud
dell'economia del Sud del mondo è che
dopo avere viaggiato moltissimo è
rientrata a Palermo e si è accorta che
deve collegare la questione meridionale
alla questione femminile Perché se
esiste una questione meridionale che ci
vede più poveri bene più poveri dei
poveri del Sud sono le povere sono le
donne Quindi c'è un legame strettissimo
tra femminismo donne e
questione meridionale e la violenza
economica che le donne subiscono è un
tema di cui ancora si parla troppo poco
l'ultima è una vostra vicina di casa e
Claudia Cammarata che ha Licata fa una
battaglia per donne e lavoro chiaramente
l'emancipazione passa attraverso il
lavoro di ogni tipo anche il lavoro
casalingo Deve essere riconosciuto come
lavoro perché lavoro
faccio parte di un'associazione che si
chiama femminote veltronici parlava di
utopia abbiamo un progetto utopico Isola
delle Femmine è in vendita abbiamo
deciso di acquistarla lanceremo presto
Un crowdfunding e potranno acquistare
delle quote di Isola delle Femmine tutte
le donne tutti gli esseri umani che si
identificano nel genere femminile tutti
gli uomini che però intesteranno la
proprietà o a una donna o un essere
umano che si identifica nel genere
femminile ma non è tanto per questo che
io ho deciso di fare parte delle
associazioni e il progetto che c'è dopo
comprarla perché per lasciarla in pace
perché il paesaggio a volte deve essere
lasciato in pace non è lo sfruttamento
L'unica cosa che possiamo fare dei
luoghi
e questo progetto Guardate che è un
progetto legato a Isola delle Femmine
sta cambiando molto la mia vita
personale ogni giorno Cioè io ci penso
che le cose possono essere Lasciate in
pace che le relazioni possono essere
possono essere Lasciate in pace ed è un
insegnamento che mi viene dalle
femminute Ribadisco per me far sì che
non ci siano più mute azioni e che la
mutazione
delle donne che prendano spazio nel
pensiero che prendano soprattutto parola
è la cosa più importante
Ci meritiamo uno spazio quantomeno
paritario Perché Se volessimo veramente
essere giusti giuste dovremmo chiedere
al maschile di tacere Quantomeno per
1900 anni ma siamo diverse e non
vogliamo ammutolire nessuno Grazie
[Applauso]